[Music]
hot welcome to buff imposter
i'm assuming i'm running away from the
buff imposter
you need to find all the milk it's like
this game was made for me
this is my game
it was made for me
go back i don't want to go back
i'm afraid of the buff imposter getting
me
the maze always changes pick up the milk
i will pick up the milk but i feel like
i mean god damn i love milk
oh no
oh where's the milk
and also where's the buff
he's here he's there where the arrow
zero are pointing where he is or is he
over there
i'm gonna guess he's in here
[Music]
what
the hell happened
what was that
what
what is that
what is it was that an eyeball
oh my god is that is that the buffing
buster looking at me
this game is terrifying i expected it to
be a meme but it's terrifying
where is buff imposter
oh no
not the long hallway
holy crap
[Music]
oh look at that
oh
wait a minute
hang on a second
ah
it's a wall
when you said it always changes
does that mean while i'm playing it
changes because that's pretty impressive
i'm not gonna lie that's
that's kind of cool
how are you doing that
wait
hey wait a minute wait wait a minute
it's dead oh
no
he's so buff
uh all right fair enough man you know
you're right you're right
but uh
yeah i made it
all right well maybe if you weren't so
bulked up you could get some endurance
oh no
i think the moral of the story is don't
go any long hallways because it's clear
nope okay
clearly it's the wrong answer hello
i thought i heard a knocking on the door
i heard it
oh that ain't good
can i get some milk been a while since
i've seen milk
he will find you willy oh
oh
free to the dark nope
[Laughter]
oh what the hell wait a minute this
isn't the same hallway i remember
it's like i'm trapped in the back rooms
with a buff imposter
god damn that imposter is buff
oh
what in the heck in hell
what is with this parallax ass window
what
man that buff imposter got fast
oh
no please big imposter man
oh don't do it dude
he was gonna do it to me
oh no
why are you running oh no i'm running
because you're chasing me i thought that
would have been very obvious
oh i'm totally in the clear now
ask me why i'm running why are you
running at me is that just how you walk
you big lumbering behemoth
he's here
yeah right no way
behind you no
hide i can't that's not how this game
works
these are incredibly unhelpful hints
funny
you funny man what was that i thought i
saw milk oh
hey but you said oh
what
i'm gonna go around you i'ma go around
you
oh milk is mine baby
this game has no right to be this good
this game has zero right to be
as competently made as it is
no
impossible
close close it
okay he was actually there something was
weird about the screen i thought maybe
he wouldn't have been there are you
lost
given to your power
i got
all right i guess i'm done now
don't follow the thump alums hey buddy
how are you
hello
seeing any thumper lumps here
i got a bad feeling i got a bad feeling
i got a bad feeling
oh what where in the hell
in the heck in the hell
where
where what what
i was just looking at this room and it
changed before my eyes
i don't like this big room
don't even think about it like
don't even think about it you can't
withstand my power
shut up don't make fun of me he's coming
yeah he is yeah he is god afraid of the
dark not quite
i'm afraid of a big burly imposter
surprisingly sexy imposter too another
big one eh
a whopper of aruma
oh
i see
i see what's going on here
uh-huh
he's coming
he's close he is
oh so you're so horny ma'am he punched
me through so many walls
oh yeah i don't believe you
oh he's behind me oh no
why is it so well done
i don't like that it's well done
all right what's behind door number
three all right what's behind door
number four
my time has come
oh you gotta make it sound so enticing
big man
not me not me not me get the other guy
man not really a lot of milk here my
bones
no you didn't scare me
this way
nil
two of three boy
[Music]
i am the best this game is
why
oh
hey big guy
okay well it's only the one door so
oh interesting
are you in
oh it here open for me wait okay follow
the arrow
i don't even need to click on the door
it just opens
the arrow was a lie okay no more arrow
okay
i don't like that
he's coming he is
oh hey big guy
hey big guy
ah
[Music]
i bet this that like that
the programming of this game is is quite
simple but it's so well done and it's
actually unsettling it's not like scary
scary it's kind of funny scary right
it's fun scary
it's funny
funny
okay i must be crazy because i don't see
him anywhere
i think he's gone i think i've gotten
rid of them
[Music]
stop okay i won't
you can't escape i'm not trying to i'm
finding milk
i just want milk
please oh thank you ah i knew it i knew
it oh i knew it
okay wait wait wait hang on hold on hold
on buddy buddy buddy
oh oh
okay bell hey pal hey pal
okay easy easy easy stuff
easiest actually
the breeziest
oh no
good thing he's slow
ah
he's gonna punch me
never mind
i did not heard something
scared potter
hello
it's here it's here it's definitely here
man
wow i did it very i don't know what the
leveling is for that's kind of strange
but okay so that is buff imposter i bet
it's made by the same guy that made that
other imposter horror game
this one's even better not gonna lie
very good scary fun good stuff link in
the description good stuff
welcome to dying of thirst
if you've ever been thirsty in your life
this game
is for you
oh oh oh i have a cup i have a cup
why does my lamp look like a martini
glass all right really throwing me into
the deep end of the pool here i
i don't know what i'm doing you know
actually i guess i don't need an
explanation i don't know why i'm
expecting one
really the whole premise of the game is
dying of thirst so i guess i'm gonna dip
my cup in the fish tank and
slurp a blurp i already fed the fish
earlier i just hope the pump isn't still
broken
well time for a drink all right anyway
i'm gonna go get a drink
of sweet delectable delicious tap water
or fridge water okay
oh yeah that's the good stuff
hello
hi who are you
who are you
god look at that smile all right anyway
well
now that that's over with time to get my
drink
anyway
pardon
oh
hi
okay all right anyway
good night
okay
fishy
uh
this is what it means when the pump's
broken
my fish are getting super
oxygenated
oh good
great
just gonna get my you know i can start
sipping at any moment
i feel like i could just continue
filling
i feel like i could have just done that
but no it's okay i go turn off the tv
play my gamecube
probably get in trouble for playing this
late yeah
hi
look at that smile are you
wait a minute
can i help you there pal i know you're
still down there you just went into that
cupboard
uh you okay
all right you come out whenever you feel
like it
if you want a drink
you just need to add oh hi
all right
maybe now i could take a sippy sip
all right good night
[Music]
oh
i thought that was my stomach
[Music]
oh
okay
short sweet to the point uh but seem to
be lacking a big jump scare finish so
lexian can you hit him with a big jump
scare finish so we can move on to the
next game okay thanks i'll leave you to
it alright have fun
did you do the big no what's that oh
oh
oh i'm sorry
i'll go
no i'll go i'll go i'll come back later
no you can still do it it'll still be
good it'll be a big finish
um but i'm i'm going to go so you can do
it but it'll be fine it'll be just scary
i'm sorry
i'm going to leave okay all right bye
bye sorry bye
[Music]
just wanted to say again i'm kind of
sorry ah sorry
welcome to the well
if you don't know this game's developer
you actually do know this game's
developer it's james from discover my
bodies and water womb world and
lips like vellum and the future release
of discover our bodies which i'm looking
forward to very much
with all that being made clear i hope
you enjoyed the well it is the first
entry in james's secret games games made
available first and foremost to my
patreon supporters
hi
you know the story
farmer seth atwood was past 80 when he
tried to sink that deep well
by his door
with only his nephew abe to help him dig
the neighbors said they worked like had
mad
actually you know what this is better
going down and down
we could only laugh and hope the old
fool would soon be sane again
but young abe had gone crazy too
so that he stove a hole through his
uncle's sorry skull and then fearfully
bricked up the well tight as glue
pastor emerson went and talked the mad
boy down
and when he abe led him to the old man's
body the pastor saw godless signs set
deep in his naked skin
they took the boy up to the county farm
but emerson still goes to see him and
they pray
after the funeral pastor emerson sent
for me
i'm guessing he sent for you as well
he was looking for someone to assist me
to clear the adword farm in cottage
we're supposed to pass along any
valuables to the young man's next of kin
but did emerson tell you this
we're supposed to stay away from the
well
for the atwoods we're chasing after some
cursed pagan treasure we hazard our
souls standing here
i've never been one for superstition i
don't know about you
of course we can work later before you
got here first thing i did was tear
those bricks away
pagan gold's worth more than any pasture
nickel a day
if you go and peer down into that hole i
bore you can only see a ladder reaching
down deeper than the light can tell
oh we ought to see how deep down it goes
before we think of heading down
don't worry i brought me old navy pap's
lead in line
i wonder just how deep seth dug down in
this dark black soil
[Applause]
[Music]
all right you just lower the line down
and i'll feed you more rope if you need
it i'm sorry
i'm sorry what
you've not ever used one of these before
eh well it ain't too hard
is that a cat is that a cat swishing its
tail like that is that is that supposed
to be a cat not whatever
we ought to work quick however wouldn't
want the pastor seeing we sniffed around
here
you don't talk too much do you well
don't mind me i'm a talker
anyway just hold down the z key to let
the line down i'll help you
oh and if jingle starts making a fuss
quiet him down just tap z to go to him
and give him some love by tapping z a
few more times eh i do it myself but i'm
over here
let's get to work
oh
i don't like this
oh i hate it
why do i hate this
20 feet okay good thank you can you stop
barking at me
okay
okay stop it
it's perfectly normal
uh-huh 60 feet
yeah
uh-huh
oh there let's take a bit of a break i'm
not as surprised
it's a beautiful day isn't it but the
atwood farm got overrun quick
the woods and the boars is rotted
through the bedroom is stinking like all
hell
it looked terrible like animals had
lived in it for months not days where
did you say you were from again
i've not heard of that place oh
cincinnati ohio anyway anyway let's get
back to it
okay
80 feet
oh it's okay oh oh oh
oh
good kitty
all right that was great
uh yes
what happened i'm sorry hello hi
the hell is that
did you feel anything on your part of
the line
let me take a look
i think something's tangled in the line
don't know how
why don't you bring it back up and we'll
both take a look how about we don't you
know this is a crazy idea and i know
i've never suggested it before but how
about we don't do that thing that you're
suggesting how about how about we don't
okay whatever
back up we go
80 feet
oh god
oh man i know this is by perfect design
but i don't want to pull up whatever
we're pulling up
is that normal
is that supposed to happen
okay whatever
huh
what am i looking at i knew something
had snagged on the line i guess that's
it huh yeah that's it yeah whatever
tangled nest of circuit boards and
nonsense that
is funny made such a damn loud noise
yeah funny about that
yeah funny
uh we are to get back to work
okay
tap z to further inspect the object you
you oh
oh what are you looking at it for
oh i missed that pepsi to further
inspect
come on now
i'm inspecting it you're a strange one
you're a strange one what the hell did
we pull up so like some blair witch
okay wait no hang on yeah i'm
on i'm on to something split it down the
middle
mirror it across the horizontal plane
cut it in half flip it match it up end
to end what do we got
okay we got that i don't know what that
is all right come on
i am go throw the lead down and i'll
hold tight
back at it then yeah you're right
hopefully with no more distractions
yeah you right about that yeah you right
about that
[Music]
what's wrong oh good kitty good kitty
nice necklace kitty
you're welcome
this is a delightful game for delightful
people like myself
20 feet
40 feet
60 feet we're about to get past the
point where we snagged on something
before
oh it's okay kitty don't worry about it
don't worry your pretty little head
you're good kitty
80 feet okay we're breaking new ground
hey there give me a moment
ah jingle ain't bothering you too much
eh good good
we're lucky to have you
how did you meet first meet with the
pastor
um i see oh jealous question to me well
uh church surprisingly had not heard of
that hospital oh never mind a hospital
you're in the college of sciences at the
university then
sure i see i see but you've taken some
divinities classes eh you're a smart one
and that book learning didn't make your
hands too soft eh
well we ought to start again
enough of my drawing
all right enough of your jaw all right
100 feet
damn how long is this line
it's okay kitty it's okay good kitty
oh
something on the line again eh
you feel it
certainly hurt it yeah i feel it
yeah
tangled again damn
bring it on up
okay
this is a good idea
this is a good idea this is a good idea
oh it's a good idea
oh it's one of those good ideas ah
oh boy
it sure is loud whatever that is
oh it's
real loud
someone's coming up you got that right
oh
what's that what in the hell is that a
good question i was asking myself the
same thing weird looking thing very
weird yeah you're right
talk about pagan that things look like a
devil
yeah makes my head hurt just looking at
it damn damn you know usually i've never
encountered many things in my i've never
many
i have not often encountered in my life
things that i look at and make my head
hurt outside of an optical illusion
usually that's a bad sign
i'm gonna inspect it
what was that did you just
dude i don't know hour the hell
a little worm just bit me
that's bad thought i felt something
looking at me for a second
that's bad
all right go and put it away maybe dig a
hole and throw it in it
maybe dig a well and throw it in it
maybe that's what the well is for
you mentioned you were at the university
yep i sure did you ever see something
like that in book
nope
yeah yeah i know i don't i didn't know
nothing about this area
don't surprise me none
my me late wife well not wife but we was
betrothed
her daddy used to go digging through the
burial mounds oh good
oh a grave robber wait a what a good way
to put a grave robber
he often found something i didn't catch
that lexington what was it
oh i didn't put it in my brain okay
thank you one day he did though wouldn't
tell me about it weird fella you ever
find yourself a lady friend oh you know
yeah
hmm it can be hard
funny i swear i saw or something on his
back
weird stuff yeah you right
all right i'm sick of looking at this
ugly thing
yeah you and me both
back her work here we go again
third time's the charm baby
where's the kitty
kitty
where's the kitty kitty's gone
everyone panic gets gone
and i got a bad feeling about this one
guys i don't know if you ask me
something
boy don't that dirt look good
in what way
i'm sorry i'm feeling funny
but don't look good look how dark it is
ad hood dug in here because he knew how
dark it was
the atwood's here so wise deep enough in
the soil that they don't even die
deep with her
what uh what what worm bit you what worm
bit you was it maybe it might have been
a worm out of like a resident evil game
or something like that okay cool
anyway i'm gonna keep putting the line
down
hey
[Music]
oh again okay all right again yeah
you gotta we'll never get this work done
god damn it
all right bring it up
what are you talking about
no i didn't say nothing to you what
oh yeah what was that about all that
dirt talk
i just been calling out the footage the
line
you feeling okay we can take a break
mind you if you really need it would it
prefer not to though
good good have you seen jingle by the
way
no
well there are certainly enough rats
around here to keep a cat busy eh okay
bring her up then man the dirt looked
good don't it
have you ever seen a pile of dirt
a
pile of dirt about yay high
looks like dirt
here we go again
oh boy
oh boy something's coming up
it's a rock my god look at that
it's a rock
wow
looks like some oh egg full of something
i was gonna say rock in fact i did say
rock
what do you mean it's not just a rock i
was i literally think it might be just a
rock man
looks like a woman's belly full of slugs
that's an odd comparison to make my
friend
it's disgusting and yet don't say
do not be horny right now
it's beautiful
he might be horny
like a child being born okay not as
horny
we have so much to give and we don't
deserve none of it
horny
she deserves it all i'm just a worm
that's 100 horny right there you better
watch yourself but
i'm just a worm me too bud me too
anyway i'm going to inspect this object
i'm just a worm
i'm
you feel odd at all
oh i feel uncomfortable that's for sure
given that i've never actually looked at
you my friend
i feel
odd i can see something like a dream
strange stuff it looks like a big
leather bag that been left out in the
sun rain
but it's moving and twitching all
strange something turned it inside out
to make a way for a beautiful lady
there's something
pulsing under it
sliding around like a snake under wax
paper again with the analogies
i don't often see snakes slithering
under wax paper my friend
we ought to get back
back to her work this wonderful work
that we have with this great job
that we secured for ourselves oh jingle
you're back
something's different about jingle
all right one more time eh
what's wrong with jingle
has jingle got lightning across jingle
20 feet
i'm gonna pet the hell out of you jingle
i'm gonna pet the
goddamn hell out of here
oh come on now we barely got down there
i don't want to even work anymore
feeling a bit sleepy
you raise it up i'll do me thing
i'll go lay down in a deep dark hole
home home on a warm dirt moon where the
worms are
oh i'm sleepy all right come on
you got it pal
60 feet
40 feet
something's coming up
oh another furry friend there
was there another ratter at atwood's had
a fluffy one eh oh looks fluffy all
right
jingle have a friend eh
[Music]
oh your jingle
how did you make yourself in two
jingle did you play a trick
but maybe you're the real jingle and the
other is someone else but
[Music]
how long has it been since she has dug
in
i see you've done well to bring her so
quickly it was a bit risky in daylight
however
perhaps if it was night it might have
been a bit cooler and there would be
fewer flies
[Music]
more importantly word had spread you
were lugging around something strange
i overheard some parishioners speaking
of it i told them you were just hauling
away some refuse from the edward estate
how long how is the temperature how long
is this
protuberating bengal what's
protuberating lixian please give me the
definition of protuberating
thank you kindly
let me take a closer look
has she told you anything else
very well we'll have to go i don't know
what's happening her body is aiding to
her parthenogenesis genesis
lexian please give me a definition of
parthenogenesis
thank you kindly
is there something wrapped around one of
her spikules
licks here please give me the definition
spike yours
thank you
the line is tangled here you see
she's in there with him in the line
it seems when his pelvic girdle was
separated it made the dangling even
worse
please don't separate my pelvic girdle
i'm very fond of that
i am envious of this man he is so close
to her
the pneuma drawn from his bloodstream is
to her as milk to a suckling babe
lexian please give me the definition of
milk i mean goddamn i love milk thank
you
in any case it's fortunate we are both
here we will have to pull loose the line
to unblock the metrador
i think we all know what metrador means
all right i will be the ballast at the
back you pull from where you're standing
pull hard but give it slack when i tell
you we don't want to hurt her
ready
pull fast till i okay here we go
i'm pulling i'm pulling him well i'm
pulling 30 feet left i'm pulling what am
i pulling what am i pulling out of what
am i pulling
hold on okay hold on oh we must not be
too hasty give some time for the fetal
form to uncoil itself a bit and we will
begin again shortly
are you well did you do that
[Music]
boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy stop give me a
moment i must inspect the metrador
my goodness
she spoke just briefly to me the subtle
body is immanetizing we're very close
[Music]
daughter of the deathless worm
the cracked bell oh the moment is at
hand indeed oh the moment is at hand
what am i pulling out of whose ass
the light what happened to the light i
can hear the chime of the bell is she
here
[Music]
my god
she's beautiful ah
[Music]
oh
oh okay
well
i am confused
that was lovely
i lovely that and apparently based on an
hp lovecraft poem which i did not know
that was the case so thank you very much
for that i will appreciate the
nightmares and thank you and have a
lovely day and thank you
that's all i have to say about that um
yeah uh yeah i thought it was great
because it's just something about
james's game style it just makes things
so disturbing but i loved it
[Music]
foreign